one of the reasons I wrote this book is
because oddly enough philosophers who
are famous notorious for being Mabel
gazers for being reflective I think in
fact philosophers are often remarkably
unreflecting about their own methodology
I wanted to draw attention to how
philosophers actually go about their
business and get them thinking more
self-consciously
about the tools they use and how they
use them a tool that everybody should be
familiar with and in fact people use it
all the time is reductio ad absurdum
arguments it's the sort of general
purpose crowbar of rational argument
where you take your opponent's premises
and deduce something absurd from them
that is you deduce a contradiction
efficiently we use it all the time
without paying much attention to it if
you say something like if he gets here
in time for supper he will have to fly
like Superman which you know is absurd
nobody can fly that fast you don't
bother spelling it out you just say you
you point out that something that
somebody imagined or proposed has an
ridiculous consequence well let's look
at one of the great Grandaddy reductio
ad absurdum arguments of all times and
that's Galileo's proof that heavy things
don't fall faster than light things
believing in friction aside he argued as
follows okay suppose you take the
premise that you're going to show it's
false suppose and heavier things do fall
faster than light things now take a
stone a which is heavier than another
stone B that means if we tied B to a
with a string B should act as a drag on
a when we drop it because a will fall
faster B will fall slower and so a tied
to B should fall slower than a by itself
but a be tied together is heavier than a
by itself so it should fall faster
should fall both faster and slower than
a by itself that's a manifest
contradiction so we know that our
premise was which we become began has to
be false that's a classic reductio ad
absurdum that's been known and named for
several millennia I guess and as I say
it's the it's the workhorse of
philosophical argumentation